Matt Lauer accuser a diese known
candidly speaks out today to making
Haley I'm coming forward and saying yes
this was consensual it was an abuse of
power
the former Today Show production
assistant is the first Lauer accuser to
reveal her identity publicly she alleges
the now fired host abused his power in
2000 she says when she was 24 years old
they engaged in a one month long affair
I expected some blowback of course
because I understand that people are
going to paint me as a homewrecker as a
[ __ ] and a [ __ ] and those are things I
have been called the now 41 year old
explains what was going through her mind
when she says Lauer lured her into their
first encounter he said meet me and I
said meet you where and he said dressing
room and in that moment I didn't have
anybody to sort of share my fears and
confusion with except for him felt
confused felt shame I was it was just
all-consuming
in a statement to ET the known explains
her decision to go public was made in
part because she feared being outed
quote the media was coming for me so
instead of allowing someone else to
write my narrative I decided to stop
protecting him blaming myself and
allowing fear to hold me hostage I have
been offered thousands of dollars for my
story and I want no part of that Zinn
own claims she was first approached by
the National Enquirer a few months after
their affair ended in 2000 this
gentleman comes with me I don't really
want to calm the gentleman this man came
up to me as I was getting out of my car
and he said I want to ask you some
questions about Matt Lauer when you told
Matt about that what did he say who did
you tell
why didn't you tell somebody and I
thought and I said well I have to tell
somebody what do you want me to do with
this it's not like he's helping me he's
discarded insignificant neither Lauer or
NBC have commented on Zhu nones
allegations
you